[Music]
i was lucky enough to in undergrad have
a scholarship that enabled me to attend
um and i remember thinking to myself
back then that you know
i wouldn't even be able to
step foot in this sort of environment
without that kind of help and i wanted
to make sure that other folks who come
after me
come to a place that's even better than
it was before
and in particular i want to make sure
folks that are
you know
black latinx that are lgbtq you know
what have you i want to make sure that
they feel as supported as possible
[Music]
bianca is just an exemplary
student advocate
a lot of the issues she is
advocating for fighting for are very
personal to her
and she does a really great job of
using that to
promote and center her fight while also
you know keeping things very respectful
and professional
one of the difficulties about working in
the dei space in particular
is that sometimes it involves a lot of
conversations that have to push people
out of their comfort zone and really
self
reflect and reflect on the mit
environment and some of the drawbacks
that might currently be there
some of these human and social problems
are harder in my opinion than our tech
problems
[Music]
i do hope that she continues up the
great work that she continues being a
wonderful resource i think she will and
i think this is something she cares
about a lot um
and i i do hope that
this inspires other people to want to
get involved
[Music]
i'm currently on the
mit's deni strategic plan steering
committee
so we've been working for over a year
now trying to formulate
an entire strategic plan for the
university
i know sometimes it can be scary to try
and tackle structural issues but really
it's what's needed to bring
mit forward and to make sure that we're
the top institute for many years to come
you